- Well, like Kristin, you
have also been on Broadway.
So it was actually the first
time "Death of a Salesman"
had an all African American cast, right?
- Yes, yes, I mean
- [Kelly] Did that feel like pressure?
- It felt like a lot of pressure.
I mean, this is a play,
it's one of the greatest American plays
ever to be written.
- [Kristin] Ever.
And your role.
- And my role as Biff is something
that a young actor just
dreams about being able to do,
let alone on Broadway.
So, when we were gonna do the play,
first, you have to understand
this play has been done so many times
- 'Cause it's classic and great.
- It's classic and great.
So you've either read it,
you've either seen it,
you have either done it in class,
so you have your own
perspective on it, right?
So how do you do it new?
How do you change someone's
perspective on something
that's been done so well so many times?
And then on top of that, it's being done
with an all Black cast.
So then you have to have the question of
is it going to resonate?
Will the language read the same way?
So, there was that pressure,
but I think what we all did with our show,
we didn't change any of the dialogue.
The script stayed the same,
but the nuances changed.
- Oh, yeah.
- You understand?
- Yes.
- So we all dug in.
We gave it everything that we had.
We gave our hearts, we gave our spirits,
and that's all you can ask someone to do
when they're on that stage.
- Yeah.
- [Kristin] Yes.
- And young Black actors,
now, they see that they
can broaden the scope
on the kind of work that they can do
and that they're able to do.
As long as the story, I believe,
speaks to our humanity on a deep level,
we'll all be able to understand it
no matter who's telling the story.
- Absolutely.
Nice.
I know, I'm like, gosh.
- So well spoken
and you're right.
- Well, you also did I hear
that you, oh, I got you, girl.
I cry all the time on
this show, check it out.
- Sorry.
- Yep, yep.
They got a whole load of 'em
over here for me.
- It's just so well said.
- [Kelly] I know, know.